a most unspeakable charge has been
brought against you
i request a duel to the death is it
different now the two of you being
together like your fathers you have so
much going on
is it very is it is it different the way
you work back in the day there was
we didn't have deadlines because nobody
cared what we were doing now
it's a little more structured right like
let's write from ten to two
you know uh because we can drop the kids
off and then we can pick the kids up you
know we can we can kind of build it
around
uh we actually have lives now which is
nice
finally
[Applause]
i think we'll write a lot more in the
future just because it was it didn't
turn out to be as time consuming as we
thought
um it was actually a lot of fun we like
hearing that because the last time the
guys did a project this big together was
almost 24 years ago on their breakout
film
goodwill hunting their new collab the
last duel won't hit theaters until
october but before matt takes a turn as
a knight
he's an oil rigged roughneck whose
daughter is accused of murder
in his new movie stillwater my daughter
is innocent
you had a chance to hang out with a few
of those roughneck guys yeah it's
one of the cool parts of my job is that
i get to kind of parachute into other
people's lives and
because i'm an actor they go like all
right well yeah you can hang out with me
for a little while and
they took us around to their oil rigs
met their families
everything i basically got from for this
portrayal came through my
my the access that these guys gave us i
loved her i know you did but everybody
thinks that i killed her
abigail breslin co-stars is matt's
daughter in this gritty drama
that was shot in france and is loosely
based on the amanda knox story
the 25 year old new yorker told us she
had to get her driver's license for the
part
so the first time that i really had to
drive was in marseille
with matt damon as my passenger all i
could think was oh my gosh she has
children
if i kill matt damon this is going to be
really bad for me um
and he taught me how to do a u-turn
which i really appreciated
[Applause]
this happened to me with julia stiles in
one of the born movies
where we had to drive and i was like oh
no oh my god we're all gonna die
abby did a great job with the driving
and we all live to tell the tale